[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and we're thrilled to have you here
we're so excited about what the future
holds and we've invested a lot to make
you successful with Google Cloud so you
can build applications faster and more
secure than ever
you may have heard Thomas kurian talk
about how we offer prescriptive Guidance
with an opinionated approach to solve
developer velocity challenges in today's
session I'm going to show you how
exactly we do this by highlighting how
Google Cloud lets you deliver secure
applications in an open manner even
though working remotely has become the
norm working faster remotely and across
distributed teams continues to be a
challenge typical friction points
include onboarding Road employees
setting up Dev and test environments and
long build times just to name a few
when it comes to security code and data
exfiltration risks are key
this is especially true in sensitive and
regulated environments
customers tell us that current solutions
to secure Dev environments can add
developer friction to the experience
for example streaming-based Solutions
May introduce unwanted latency
in running your specific containers may
not be fully supported
solving developer velocity challenges
requires a two-pronged approach
how do we not only make it easier for
developers to build applications but
also easy for it admins to securely
scale in Dev environments
to address this
I'm excited to announce the availability
of cloud workstations
think of cloud workstations as providing
pre-configured but customizable
developer environments in the cloud with
your favorite dev tools pre-installed
and up to date
Cloud workstations come with multi-ide
support such as IntelliJ pycharm Ryder
sea lion code OSS and others as part of
this fully managed experience Cloud
workstations can provide security
capabilities as you code which can be
extended to other parts of your software
supply chain from build dependency
management to deployment
on the product side we are taking those
efforts to the next level with the
launch of software delivery Shield
software delivery Shield provides a
fully managed end-to-end software supply
chain security
this starts with the IDE and includes CI
CD pipelines deploy time policies and
runtime security posture
so while you're focused on writing code
software delivery Shield or SDS is
helping to make sure your organization's
security policy is consistently enforced
across the software delivery process
enabling you to develop faster in
addition to what we've covered we've
also been focused on helping remove
barriers across our data platform
allowing developers to build data-driven
applications faster
after all data often Powers the most
impactful experiences
we're providing integration with vertex
AI our AIML platform
this enables inferencing directly within
the database transaction
in addition we're announcing in preview
spanner integration with vertex AI
this integration allows data scientists
to build their models easily in vertex
AI and developers to access those models
using the SQL query language it's a
great time to be a developer because
software is enabling businesses to
reimagine how they're providing more
engaging experiences
in doing this with the peace of mind
that security is embedded at every step
of the way and everything I just
described was designed to help you focus
on what you love writing code fast
we're excited to create this future
together thanks for joining us
[Music]
Yang VP of cloud AI industry Solutions
and I'm sudhir husband I'm senior
director of product management for data
analytics at Google Cloud the last few
years have led us to a Tipping Point
with AI adoption where we have seen the
impact of AI across more and more
organizations and more and more use
cases
organizations for many Industries and
varying level of ml expertise are
solving business critical problems with
AI from creating compelling customer
experience to optimizing operations to
automating routine tasks these
organizations learn to innovate faster
and ultimately get ahead in the
marketplace
but how do they get there first
challenge start with data it is the
challenge to manage this growth and
complexity it is a challenge to prepare
data for AI and ml usage
second AI expertise is scarce how many
AI experts do you need to get your first
model into production what about the
next set of use cases
and finally if you have all the pieces
in place the road from prototype to
production can still take months if not
years
how can you scale faster with confidence
I'm proud to announce the general
availability of big lake to help you
break the data silos and unify your data
lakes and warehouses Big Lake will also
support Apache Iceberg which is becoming
the standard for open source table
formats for your data leaks and soon we
will also add support for other formats
like Delta Lake and hoodie our built-in
support for Apache spark in bigquery
will allow data practitioners to create
bigquery stored procedures unifying
their work in spark with their SQL
Pipelines
today we are announcing support for
unstructured data in bigquery through
object tables object tables enable you
to take advantage of common security and
governance across your data you can now
build data products that unify
structured and unstructured data in
bigquery
this makes bigquery One-Stop solution to
store manage and process all types of
data at global scale Google Cloud
addresses this challenge head on by
offering a wide range of capabilities
that can increase the reach of AIML to
more users and help your scarce resource
your data scientists to achieve greater
productivity for some workloads faster
is what it's all about
I am excited to introduce vertex AI
Vision a revolutionary end-to-end
computer vision application development
service
that helps you to be able to reduce the
amount of time it takes to build
computer vision application from days to
minutes at a fraction of the cost was it
easy to use drag and drop interface and
pre-trained model for common tasks
vertex AI vision is the One-Stop shop to
build deploy manage computer vision
application
we hope you have enjoyed this session
thank you so much for attending
[Music]
I'm Andy Goodman's general manager and
VP of engineering for databases at
Google cloud and I'm excited to share
with you what's next for Builders and
data engineers at Google Cloud our
mission is to accelerate every
organization's ability to digitally
transform
and a large part of that is helping
customers innovate faster with the
unified open and intelligent data
platform
we do this by focusing on four key areas
let's start with the first Focus area
creating a unified and integrated data
Cloud if you're operational and
analytical data
the way we've built our core services
such as Cloud spanner bigtable alloy DB
and bigquery is truly differentiated
building on this customers need to have
easy movement of data within the data
cloud
we heard you and that's why we announced
in preview data stream for bigquery
data stream for bigquery provides easy
replication of data from operational
database sources such as loadb postgres
MySQL and Oracle directly into bigquery
this is special because we worked
closely with the bigquery team to
develop an optimized integration to
replicate database updates in real time
at very low latency
setup is just a few simple clicks the
second Focus area is our continued
commitment to open source and Open
Standards for increased flexibility and
portability without vendor lock-in
we offer many services that are fully
compatible with the most popular open
source engines such as MySQL postgres
and redis we're focused on making Google
Cloud the best place to run your
postgres workloads
we offer you not one not two but three
fully managed services that support the
postgres interface
first Cloud SQL for postgres it is our
Enterprise ready fully managed
relational database service
you get the same experience of Open
Source postgres with the strong
manageability availability and security
capabilities of cloud SQL
and you can use the same service apis to
also manage your MySQL and SQL Server
databases second alloy DBS are fully
managed postgres compatible database
service ready for your top tier
workloads and for modernizing your
legacy proprietary databases in the
cloud
in our performance tests alloyodb is
more than four times faster than open
source postgres and two times faster
than Amazon's comparable postgres
compatible service for transactional
workloads
it also delivers up to 100 times faster
analytical queries than standard
postgres and finally we've also added a
postgres interface for spanner our
transformative relational database with
unlimited global scale strong external
consistency and up to five nines
availability
with the postgres interface for spanner
developers can take advantage of
familiar tools and skills from the
postgres ecosystem
and to further democratize access to
spanner we recently announced a free
trial to give Builders an easy way to
try out spanner at no cost
get started building with spanner today
the third Focus area is around how we
are infusing Ai and ml across
data-driven workloads we use AIML across
our database Technologies to make our
services more intelligent
capabilities such as Cloud SQL cost
recommenders and alloy DB autopilot
enable dbas and devops teams to manage
performance and capacity for large
fleets of databases
in addition to infusing Ai and ml into
our databases we're providing
integration with vertex AI our Ai and ml
platform to enable model inferencing
directly within the database transaction
I'm therefore excited to announce today
in preview the integration of vertex AI
with spanner
you can now use a SQL query in spanner
to call a model and vertex AI
with this integration both alloy DB and
now spanner can simply call vertex AI
models using SQL in operational
transactions allowing data scientists to
build their models easily in vertex Ai
and developers to access these models
using the SQL query language our final
Focus area is around empowering Builders
to be more productive with Innovative
one-of-a-kind developer experiences
we've introduced Cloud SQL query
insights for postgres and MySQL in
addition we make Cloud SQL cost
recommenders generally available and
introduce postgres system insights in
preview
today we're excited to announce the
preview of security and performance
recommenders for cloud SQL thank you
enjoy the rest of next
[Music]
hello I'm Sachin Gupta vpgm for
infrastructure at Google Cloud
the roles of Enterprise Architects and
developers are evolving
not only do you have to keep the lights
on you are expected to stay on top of
the ever-changing trends and
technologies that create business value
and you have to do all of this while
lowering costs and improving performance
so it infrastructure runs quickly and
smoothly
Your Role is critical to a successful
transformation with Google Cloud you can
innovate faster and more easily while
optimizing costs we know organizations
like yours still have a lot of
infrastructure to migrate and we are
committed to helping you migrate more
securely and efficiently Cloud TPU V4
delivers industry leading ml training
performance and scale with six terabits
per second interconnect you can run
large-scale training workloads up to 80
faster and up to 50 cheaper compared to
Alternatives today we are announcing a
new industry Consortium the open xla
project that will unite an ecosystem of
leading machine learning compiler
Technologies and accelerate and simplify
machine learning Innovation these open
source AI contributions enable you to
take your AI idea and turn it into
reality easily and at low cost VMware
engine is a fully managed native Google
service that helps you lift and shift
your VMware applications to Google Cloud
faster and easier
we are the first external provider to
support vmware's Cloud Universal program
which makes it easier for you to migrate
to the cloud
and with built-in point-and-click
migration tools and our instant
provisioning feature you can get
workloads running in your private cloud
in less than one hour we are continuing
to scale VMware engine by increasing
support from 64 to 96 nodes per private
Cloud all with four lines of
availability in a single site and a
dedicated 100 gigabit per second Network
this provides high performance and
reliability for your most demanding
production workloads next I'm really
excited to announce C3 VMS
it is the first VM on the market to
feature the latest generation of Intel
Sapphire Rapids processors and is built
on new Intel Google co-designed
infrastructure processing units or ipus
all of this together means
differentiated performance security
isolation and flexibility
C3 is the first VM in our Fleet with 200
gigabits per second low latency
networking to support a variety of
workloads such as data processing web
serving and high throughput HPC
workloads moving on to another product
built to Leverage The ipu Google cloud
hyperdesk is the next generation of
block storage which will be available on
both compute engine and gke we are
decoupling block storage performance
from the VM allowing you to tune your
storage performance to your workload
needs our new flexible committed use
discounts or Flex Cuts can make it
easier to save and manage costs across
teams by giving you region and VM family
flexibility our new migration Center can
reduce complexity time and cost
by providing key capabilities in
migrating and modernizing to Virtual
machines containers or serverless
Computing dual run lets you replicate
your Mainframe workload in Google cloud
and run the two environments in parallel
this allows you to confirm successful
operations in Google Cloud
before your cutover which can massively
reduce risk
these three defining pillars for Google
Cloud infrastructure
transformative
optimized and easy
are the key tenets behind our
intentional engineering efforts thank
you
[Music]
my name is Omar Gandhi a senior director
of product management from Google cloud
and I'm joined by my colleague Jerome
Sims IMR
and we're both excited to share with you
some new products and capabilities we're
introducing at next this year at Google
Cloud our mission is to accelerate every
organization's journey to digitally
transform the business and when it comes
to devops we serve customers of all
sizes and types today and our goal is to
make devops on Google Cloud
easy for your organization as well and
to fulfill this Mission we focus on four
key areas which address the key
challenges we hear from these customers
every day this year we are launching
many new products and capabilities
across all of these four areas and now
I'm going to hand over to my colleague
Jerome to tell you more thanks Amar
software supply chain security is
becoming an increasingly critical
concern for many devops teams and to
help you better protect your software
Supply chains we're very excited to
bring you software delivery Shield
software delivery Shield is a
comprehensive yet modular set of
capabilities that spans a set of Google
Cloud products delivering a fully
managed end-to-end solution to help
protect your software supply chain to
help you better secure your applications
during development we are launching
Cloud workstations
a new service which provides a fully
managed local development environment on
Google cloud with built-in security
measures we are also giving your
developers tools to help them code
faster with greater security
with Cloud code Source protect
developers will get real-time security
feedback as they work in their IDE when
your developers are coding in Cloud
workstations artifact registry and
container analysis can give them a
secure space to store and manage their
container images and language packages
and also scan them for vulnerabilities
you can now do unpush scanning for Maven
and go packages in containers and for
non-containerized Maven packages as well
to help you improve the security of your
open source dependencies our assured
open source software service provides
over 250 packages across
Java and python in continuing to help
secure your pipelines I'm really excited
to announce Cloud build now supports
salsa level 3 bills
finally
to help secure the runtime environment
we're introducing a new set of security
features in gke gke can now help assess
your container security posture and give
you active security guidance for
customers on cloud run we're introducing
new enhancements to Cloud runs security
panel it now displays software supply
chain security insights when your
developers are building application
oftentimes they will need databases I'm
happy to introduce Cloud SQL security
recommender it can now automatically
monitor the security posture of your
databases alert you on potential
security vulnerabilities to make
multi-clown easier for you we're
introducing a set of new features to our
anthos platform anthos customers can now
enjoy a unified management experience
everywhere from a single Google Cloud
console
and to drive consistent security
governance and observability across a
fleet of clusters spanning all
environments whether on-prem hybrid or
multi-cloud
in addition ansos now supports VM
deployments for your Edge environments
and to help our customers develop and
operate more sustainably I'm pleased to
announce that carbon footprint is now
generally available
carbon footprint introduces a new level
of transparency to support you in
meeting your climate goals integrating
and scaling your devops tool chain is a
challenge for many devops teams and for
that I am happy to announce our managed
service for Prometheus is now GA in
addition
to make continuous deployment easier for
you we added integration between Cloud
deploy and Cloud run and to make the use
of logs easier on Google Cloud I'm
excited to announce log analytics
through an Innovative partnership with
bigquery Cloud logging now allows your
devops teams to get more value out of
the logs through the power of SQL
queries
with these capabilities your
organization can adopt a more secure
intelligent and sustainable devops
practice on behalf of Jerome and I we
hope you have a great next 2022.
[Music]
my name is Sunil Podi and I'm the VP and
general manager for Google Cloud
security
as many of you know organizations large
and small are realizing that digital
transformation and the changing threat
landscape
requires a ground-up security
transformation
attackers tactics techniques and
procedures have evolved as their targets
have shifted and the desired outcomes
have changed long gone are the days of a
limited number of malicious nation-state
actors only targeting specific
governments or critical infrastructure
these days New Normal is persistent
attacks and off-the-shelf attack tooling
leveraged by sophisticated threat actor
gangs and nation states
and these folks are primarily focused on
financial gain and business disruption
across the mainstream Enterprise from
the mid-market credit union bank to a
very large Enterprise in the fortune
500. as a new member of Google Cloud
family mannion brings expertise and
threat intelligence and Consulting to
double down on Google's commitment to
security and manual threat intelligence
were always Vigilant tracking threat
actors across the Cyber domain as they
seek to spy steal and sabotage the
networks of organizations around the
world while cyber attacks used to play
out completely behind closed doors the
threat has changed and we're seeing an
enormous amount of activity in full
public view State and criminal
adversaries aren't just quietly hacking
victims they're creating public
spectacles which are designed to
undermine The credibility of
Institutions and companies despite
rumors to the contrary ransomware is not
dead those actors are still going strong
but the nature of their activity is
always changing Manny and Google cloud
share a strong commitment to security
and will work together to keep our
customers Defenders and the entire
Global Community safe now as many of you
know mandian clearly shares our mission
to reinvent how Enterprises detect and
respond to threats and incidents we are
bringing the best of Google to
Enterprises with Security Solutions for
your on-prem private or multi-cloud
environments
and we are helping organizations address
these top of Mind security initiatives
across a variety of dimensions
starting with Cloud governance and
digital sovereignty now as most of you
know digital sovereignty has become top
of mind for many of you internationally
governance and sovereignty are Global
issues with regulations and many unique
compliance requirements so the core of
Google's and Google Cloud's approach is
putting at Carbon controls in your hands
transforming security for me
is all about how security can be a
business enabler while making sure that
team Embraces change and leverages all
the latest Cloud native security
controls available to us
to transform our security program we are
really focused on three key areas
security transformation to support
business growth zero trust by default
and threat detection and response going
Cloud native so we've made significant
investments in our Beyond Corp Alliance
alongside strategic Partners such as
Palo Alto and a variety of other
partners in the ecosystem this now gives
you comprehensive zero trust options
to secure private and SAS app access
while mitigating internet threats across
managed or unmanaged devices so in
closing you may recognize that the pace
of innovation
on this path to Invisible security has
not slowed down thanks again stay secure
and have a great rest of next
[Music]
hello everyone it is an honor to kick
off this session as the new leader for
the Google workspace business
some of you are current customers who
use workspace every day at work and some
of you are considering it for the first
time regardless of which Camp you're in
every time that you use Gmail or Google
Chat calendar Drive dogs meet in your
daily life you are using workspace
bridging communication and collaboration
across these products is the magic of
workspace our mission is to meaningfully
connect people so they can create build
and grow together first let's
acknowledge that meetings are not going
away
but they can be dramatically improved to
make the most of meetings we've
introduced features like automatic light
adjustments and noise cancellation so
that you can look and sound your best
companion mode gives everyone a front
row seat in hybrid meetings whether
they're joining from their phone or from
a conference room
and to reduce digital fatigue we've
added features like co-presenting and
the ability to unpin your own video tile
attracting and retaining Talent is top
of mind for many of us as we prepare for
tomorrow's Workforce a new study stated
that 75 of recent college graduates
prefer working in Google workspace and
today I'm excited to announce new ways
in which we're making workspace even
more powerful capabilities like adaptive
framing give everyone in a crowded
conference room a chance to be seen
we've also introduced Auto
transcriptions in me not just in English
but soon in French German Portuguese and
Spanish
today I'm excited to share the
web-bringing smart canvas to more places
in workspace starting with Google Slides
it's speaker Spotlight in slides we're
bringing the Storyteller and the story
together from far more integrated
engaging view creating focus and
engagement I am thrilled to announce
that we're opening up smart canvas for
third-party applications new smart chips
for Salesforce zendesk figma and other
partners will allow people to view and
engage with this Rich third-party data
in the flow of the work rather than
switching tabs or context our
groundbreaking client-side encryption
feature allows customers to have
complete control over access to their
data today we're excited to announce
that we are extending client-side
encryption to Gmail and Google Calendar
we're introducing apis for meet and chat
and a meet add-on SDK that allows you to
bring the power of these tools directly
into the third-party apps that you're
using every day
our partners figma and Asana are using
that new SDK to embed their apps
directly into me
the new figma add-on will enable teams
to collaborate on figma design files and
fig Jam digital whiteboards directly in
Google me I am psyched by how we can
help users and customers today and I'm
so excited by where we're headed thank
you everyone for joining us we hope you
check out the on-demand content and the
breakout sessions for much more on
workspace bye for now
[Music]